millions and millions of dollars have
been spent taxpayer dollars our
attention has been focused not in actual
matters of state or significance but on
the collusion story that apparently
swung the 2016 election now we find out
that the singular person at the center
of that this Russian lawyer vessel in
Disgaea has never been interviewed she
says by the independent counsel how can
that be and what does it tell us about
the nature of this investigation
joe-joe Geneva has been watching
carefully as a former US Attorney for
the District of Columbia and he joins us
tonight so I I just want to say I don't
have any s truck information I don't
really know but she says she has not
been interviewed if that's true what
does that tell us it tells us basically
that this investigation by Muller from
the beginning has been a fraud it had
nothing to do with collusion by the
Russians and they knew that from the
very beginning mr. Comey knew that from
the very beginning because he knew that
there was no basis for any of the FISA
warrants that there no were no foreign
agents of the Russian government
involved in the case from the beginning
and that's why he refused to breathe the
gang of eight on Capitol Hill about the
existence of the Russian probe in the
dossier
for months and months because he knew if
he briefed them he would have to answer
specific questions about the basis for
the investigation and no bases existed
can the just as a procedural matter I
think it's meaningful can the FBI
director saying no to Congress when they
say come tell us about something that
we're supposed to be overseeing can he
just say no well he kept it from them
they didn't know that the Russian probe
the counterintelligence probe existed he
kept it from them
now if they had asked him he clearly
would have lied about it because he's
lied about it ever since the opportunity
arose he he unfortunately was confronted
by the existence of the investigation
and the failure to disclose it by a
congresswoman
during the initial investigations into
this when the whole thing blew up that's
unbelievable so I would think that both
parties and Democrats think they're
gonna take control the government at
some point and they may they have an
interest in having an FBI that they can
trust that we can all trust so why is
nobody on the Left calling for charges
to be filed against the former deputy
director of the FBI
according to the IG lied isn't that
perjury is that wouldn't that warrant a
prosecution well there's no doubt that
McCabe should be prosecuted whether or
not he will be remains to be seen I I
tend to think that it's almost
impossible not to
now that they've charged Michael Flynn
with lying right and George papadopolis
and all these little people who've done
absolutely nothing wrong there's no way
you can't charge Andrew McCabe remember
he's a senior government official senior
law enforcement official lied under oath
three times according to the Inspector
General no way he can't be charged it's
just up there we can be certain when the
the IG of the FBI issues its report that
we can trust that right oh absolutely I
mean I don't think there's any doubt
that mr. Horowitz has done a credible
job there's no reason to doubt him in
addition the internal watchdogs of the
FBI themselves their own office of
Professional Responsibility their ethics
watchdogs said that he lied to them so
if you have a senior law enforcement
official who lied under oath repeatedly
about a criminal matter why would he be
defended by liberals where are the civil
libertarians on the left because the
Liberals aren't liberals anymore they're
progressives
and remember it was the progressives who
cated who created all the horrible
movements in the 1920s and 30s and those
people no longer think they are reacting
they're against this president they hate
him there are no principles anymore for
them they believe that everything should
be sacrificed for the thrill of having
power and doing whatever you want to do
to shut down the American people's
throat they have abandoned all pretense
of believing in free speech in believing
in accountability and in belief and
believe it or not they have become
proponents of the FBI being an
organization that lies to the Americans
they sent hundreds of thousands of
dollars to a senior law enforcement
official who was fired for lying under
oath and the left is supporting it they
are absolutely supporting it because
they hate this president so much that
they are willing to sacrifice the
Constitution and any core beliefs that
you have as a real liberal it's
unbelievable what's really distorting a
lot of people Joe Joe Jennifer thank you
for that perspective thank you